Hey, how's it going bros, my name is Pewdiepie. I'm so excited because "Revelmode", which is
basically me and a bunch of awesome
Youtubers,
let's-let's show their beautiful faces-
Have partnered up with Humble Bundle to
support the charity "Crisis Text Line".
I'm so excited because it's an amazing
charity. Over 65 million,
only in America, suffer from mental
illness, whether it's from depression
anxiety, homophobia, bullying, eating
disorders, suicidal thoughts,
the Crisis Text Line supports these
people. They offer 24-hour support in the
US for people with mental problems.
I think it's brilliant, it's a brilliant
charity. So you bros and everyone is coming
together to support these people in
crisis.
You could either volunteer to become a crisis counselor,
you could donate to support the charity directly, or you could just buy games. So
Humble Bundle has a bunch of games
unlocked:
we got Disco Dodgeball, Nidhogg, Choice Chamber, Golf with your Friends
Skullgirls, Spelunky, Roguelands, and
Rocket League. You can pay whatever you want
for these games and choose what goes to the developer and what choose to go to
the charity, and if you pay more than $15 you unlock Rocket League. You can basically
get all these games for whatever price
you want and support charity.
I think that's amazing. There's no reason not to go and check out this link.
I think we can really make a difference
in an awesome way, and this is it. I'm so excited.
And as promised we gonna do a bunch of live streams. The first one
is on Wednesday, July 13 with Jack and Ken.
I might be there as well, who knows. Second one is Friday, July 15.
It's gonna be me and Kwebbel and
probably Cry and some other people.
Tell Cry he needs to join.
Sunday, it's just going to be just me, baby.
Wednesday,
it's going to be Jelly, Kwebbel, Slogo.
The full schedule is down below.
I'm going to definitely be streaming  the 15, the 17, and the 24.
I strongly recommend that you check out the link to the Humble Bundle and the
Crisis Text Line in the description.
#revel4good, post that shit
everywhere.
Let the good people know about Revelmode finally doing something. We've been
sitting on our asses for way too long. And that's it, make sure you catch the
live streams, all the info is in the
description - What time,
what date. I think it's gonna be an
awesome time, we'll just hang out
when it will be live. I'm so excited for
this. Check out the link in description,
start donating, get the Humble Bundle.
LET'S DO THIS. Alright bros, see you in the livestream, and as always, stay awesome bros!